boom Mic Check 1 2 1 2 we're here we're
here we're here
naina edge this is your host from the
standout podcast and I'm here by my side
kick with my sidekick sorry introduce
you Robin Robin Robin go and just Tommy
introduce all to the people bro if I
kick a Caribbean strongest hair in the
sea Wow and we are joined today by our
first guest being abused in the first
two minutes our first guest
do you know how that feels the first
guest our first guest his name is chip
he's here good friend of ours very good
friend of us I'm only here because of my
age the same agent today we're gonna be
talking about turning turning 30 well
when we turn so let's kick it off my
first question to you boys is well we're
start off with oldie how did you feel
when you woke up as a 30 year old talk
to me how did I feel you know I didn't
actually fairly different mom was fun
nothing Dominican Republic oh no more
void the depression always a regular
thing they're different countries they
want the pressure of invited and to be
fair you ain't gonna have many friends
are you a new ones yeah none of that
crisis stuff in it I feel like I had my
kind of confliction of getting older
when I hit 29 come on yeah yeah what's
the big year when I turned 4 just like
that's cool just a thing that's it I had
the opposite I think you know um my um
proper not like a reflective person I
just crack on in it if she's going bad
you crack on it she's very good crackle
and whatever significance finking about
life that's proper out of character as
well I think it just came bare forced
and it is like it's the most defining
aged at all so far big it is bigger than
it felt bigger than anything
not because it's crazy because you know
we're not you're younger you look at
people and they said no 25 or 30 when
you're 15 and you're like blood blood
say like I mean uni be an 18 or 19
yeah chat chatting together saying yeah
30 I'll be thinking I'll be thinking
like why you know at home so I'm
thinking I must be open to the same
thing happened to me actually Bob weeks
ago yeah I was in housing cut yeah I'm
just changed just as weeks ago by the
way into this thing we're just chatting
chatting chain and then I go to Twitter
and come back and some Knicks brothers
trying to calm in it yeah so I'm just
love whatever she just being me the best
dish of him you know how girls are yeah
and then when he cut she goes to me oh I
bet he's like four hours fell I'm 29 at
this time fam I'm thinking this is peak
him oh god I gotta get out of here
and I was bad and I was the end of that
and I and it made me feel old
she wasn't in 22 and she said that guy
must have been what's he doing here bet
he's that fairy
yeah we all have when we used to be all
these older sis standing by the room
he'd be like rod do you thought you
shouldn't go out now now exactly yeah I
know
but remember when you're younger
you're thinking your life and choosing
Camden or loose I went there when we
were proud bro yeah proud you can feel
apart apart from is there anything else
that makes you feel that well anything
else that makes you feel a bit old any
apart obviously that that's like that's
like the club in and going out BH on it
yeah so when I see people that everyday
pre-employment check some new people
come to the job know when I'll see you
passport and it's like 22 years old or
18 nighttime oh alright
oh we play the game that get older
awesome like young 16 it's everything on
22 now people the time bomb when do I
feel yeah I think yeah you're right it's
when you're about in work and your
chance people some people in your lights
people you like people you I'm gonna
love but this week I know I've been
doing this been doing that I'm going
here today I'm going to short it and
when they finally ash you have to copy
told you like I'm food and this sure but
we all have that view you know I mean
when we were that age we all like we
should have been this that was built up
from like face as a definitive [ __ ]
point in it yeah like I said it's built
up from
this ginger membrane press input my
secondary school do you have it going
you better if we're not married by 30
we'll get married like [ __ ] lad what do
you mean oh yeah because we do
everything later now like our parents
without kids and a yard by now and our
generation this is the thing is well
that's different women I'm sorry to be
like the boy that's gonna come right now
go for the courtroom right now [ __ ]
everyone have a backbone man people
gonna do yes Oh see there's certain
things yeah some things I'm gonna say
but I think women especially have this
view in their mind like right I need to
be with the guy I met when I was 15 and
we're engaged like they're not like
childhood sweetheart like that's how
they see it because that's how probably
their parents that's cuz that's why I
think maybe turning 40 for them and
let's say let's say they're in the same
position are you saying if they took
they don't have that it's panic mode yet
nobody gotta be there
well cuz you same biological clock
that's that's realms week that's why I
believe they are as a man you know I'm
too like Faye 540 but the woman if you
hit Faye and you haven't got a long-term
relationship or so on that you can see
your future and you want kids speak
that's why I think men I don't if the
words were I think men are more romantic
than women because we can take our time
how many girlfriends I've had in your
life one in it one bro one we can wait
and if they're not right it nah work it
doesn't work
fairness is true though we can that's on
me that's all we can wait
skills maybe get to a point where
they're like all right like they spend
their life having this long list of
criteria it's perfect man that British
Army back but they end up they end up
with Brian the estate agent who's got
the company cause if that bro and that
he's dead firm
he's not even jokes can't Reese can
[Laughter]
easily there man you know you don't have
men who wear helmets and have a Boris
bag does even make sense man that's why
I didn't and then they go to working in
their plane away from saying I think
there is I don't care about saying I
think there is a bit of a panic mode
goes with Britain's and it's true is and
every and every day every first day they
go with on a on a say on internet dating
or even just a date they can't be
children just have a nice date because
they're initially looking at you and
thinking are you the one and that's dead
for them and dead for you so already
you're failing cuz how you gonna prove
that you're back on the first date
like what like this man who's you people
people people wait man wait you can wait
we don't here and I think at the end of
the day like we know that it's a long
life in it and you don't have made a
mistake yeah but I think that's a
personality thing cuz I've got bridge in
so you have different girlfriends every
season so I guess bet their view is yeah
that their view is just kid just just do
it into it works out in it we're I think
we're we're quite similar were in
different way we're just like we can
even see someone for a while and never
just like if there's something then she
doesn't jump over that River in it yeah
yeah but yeah that's my view you know my
party was way below I was I love my
party
just seeing everyone showing you love
this light button to be fair weather is
your third year of lat well what party
was a smash that colorful my hair my
29th my 29 point off what do you do went
to that place in them Islington oh I
think your 30th obviously everyone else
you go out and have a possum I think
your furry F is you do something for
yourself
I have small birthdays but I felt like
my firt if it was a good opportunity
because obviously as you get older and
everyone's got the girlfriends and jobs
it's just harder to see have such a big
party yours was waiting everyone knows
about me in some Union spread some
school primary school football and and
they were seeing each other for the
first time in years and it was like give
a [ __ ] yeah and I knew it was gonna be
like that and I don't really like it
like it's bear pressure like yeah and
even even on the day that it was just
like you have not anxiety but your host
in it so you have to spend you have to
like devised at a time if everyone isn't
it's not you should obviously you're
different cuz I'm asking me I was but
like I'm not I wouldn't say I'm babe but
I'm I'm always I'm always doing
something I'm always you know I mean
about with these people I'm out with
that people you know they I just have a
lot of friends and it's not for long
with that
don't be Joe Matt's popular I'm sorry
and ago so we were out here
and I must have been cause I was I was
young 27 so I didn't even have this
strong blackpool different man anyway
some chick I musta left some chick come
up to Rick homos lat I'll see that boy
you adjust with can you give him a
number obviously if he wins immunity is
but at the same time that's great memory
from you young good new faces maybe I
think because last year I had a great
year let me just have a party and let me
just get licked I had in a week everyone
wear a hat in a week let's have a good
time so if you saw what I saw if you had
a bad year you would have done that oh
no still would have done it but like my
my I wouldn't say I was out oh because
I'm turning furry let me have this party
I would add the party anyway I think
that 30th birthday feel like you're 28%
exactly oh you got a point there but I'm
just saying like you got celebrate wins
as well I think it's a very English
thing to be modest modest yeah we don't
that celebrate your wins and if you talk
about your successes of what you've done
and your big big all the time every time
depends when it depends when when like
there's different different stages 16 or
18 or 21 or 25 all of those are
different
goes back to what we were saying earlier
about will your saw are told when you're
younger not what you mean
Eli yeah and that's on me but then also
as well from some people that might be
from where you're brought up that might
be from Cole who your bore up that might
be some culture that might be from
genomic what you'll see you do your
reading in books up janar means so if
you look at African parents and I'm sure
you were to be married is a totally
different world right and we're totally
different to how they came here yeah
your parents when you were young college
[Laughter]
that said like when she was casa milà or
telling me off like you're not Caribbean
your mom your mom so what if you brought
if you're not with the police or brought
back a girl girl home your Bob would say
don't be Jamaican
to make it one note to be a bit louder
or a bit more acepted hmm in terms of I
let's say let's say I let's go let's go
football wise right hmm let's say 'i'm
right walk into a bar oh you're right in
92 everyone's loving him Tony your boa
walk in half yeah but what I'm saying is
like Ian right what Jamaican you come
before you know I'm saying Tony oboe
welcome that
do you get why me like so Ricky your
parents probably your Nana and that were
what here Ian Wright grew up as an
Englishman yeah exactly from his from
how many generations deep are you in
terms of comet England
so my yeah how many generations deep I
don't know the math just my granddad was
actually born here yeah but they're my
but a Mumma have a grandparents did you
make and buy my parents so that's what I
think
that's what I think they meant by you're
not Jamaican in terms of maybe they were
just looking at is in your African you
can't be doing all this stuff because
race yeah taking over the English yeah
like they like you might know it might
not be a so - because you're African by
if you had your make them because
they're more acceptance Jamaicans cuz
they were here before us you can do you
get why I'm saying
now so everyone wants to be African bro
that's another conversation but imagine
imagine one magic we were in primary
school people used to be like mud huts
in Ghana yeah that's another
conversation because the odds are there
is nice in your parents kind of drilled
into you the the points of
school uni work yeah so my parents never
really spoke about like oh you need to
be married you need to have kids that
just want you to be successful when I
think they saw it like you need to do a
lot you need to get there they didn't
see all this traveling stuff you know I
mean yeah that sort of thing but
obviously then again my mom and dad
often they're a bit more like
westernized Western idea now you like
you hear my mom she sounds so like
obviously when I got the chance to go to
America do your thing you know I mean
like I think as we got older they
started to learn and they were so it
became more so with it were they
strictly in school not strict on me in
school but they said from day know if
you miss about you and that plane back
to Ghana Cedis oh yeah and they were
like you'll be washing your boxes
interesting I guess this is why I'm kind
of more proud of myself because I didn't
have that so you push you push to model
to do so you had no one telling you not
diluting my upbringing but it was there
was no sense of like it was go learn and
do mistakes and whatever in it exact so
so it's all person you had you had it I
had examples of what to do right and
what like the bad things like I knew I
acordes isn't for me this is what I
can't do I really want to do because I'm
told
alright cool to do everything every time
I stop myself it wasn't the full of [ __ ]
my mom gonna bust man or sentence and
meats and bad bad you dude [ __ ] but
where I am I was good in school
I was giving everyone I grew up with in
my school didn't finish who when where
ever done whatever yeah and I was the
same as them but I finish I went to
Union first person my family to go to
university that's so I never had I never
had a rumor of I need to go to uni or by
30 I need to do this it was never
drilled it was never drilled into me so
and I think my personality is to not
really have goals but I think that work
for some people and it doesn't and I got
to crack on in it maybe yeah maybe maybe
that's why it works maybe we never know
me I definitely I definitely use and
indulge in it differently yeah and I
curate IQ right my feet if do you know
what you know I mean better I curate my
feet so obviously your feed is something
that you see and what you see every
module because this is and every like
influence every [ __ ] [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
that's not doing nothing for me so now
all I follow his directives I'm a
directors are just full of bear
directors and I'm fans or I follow
brands I follow and then friends things
that can escalate me because if I'm
tonight I'm putting that in this will be
ruined I'm putting that in my head more
than anything else I do yeah by happy by
happy so you have to curate it if you're
just flippantly following [ __ ] and doing
[ __ ] and not really understanding what
is going into your brain
especially at furry which is dangerous
what's eating all these 20 year old
influences with date with their keys and
governor just bought my first house yeah
I've seen also seen every of seabag
girls from your school with their hand
saying oh yeah well mentally strong but
is hard to not have some sort of
comparison and yeah
and which is bulleted the person but
then they and people and he showed the
good side of their life very wise man
told me only believe 60% of what you see
on social media so I never take anything
I see voice only believe we percent of
what you see so what other people are
doing on social media if anything I
think I'm more I'm more of an idiot on
social media now than I was before in
terms of that a post house tip when you
first met me did I post an interview no
now I'm active like just posting jokes
here and there I think I'm a bit more
relaxed - now before is a bit stiff flat
because you up hold light seems to be
under the radar the way I live my life
so so if you go back so far would you
the dumbest now you can go look at my
stuff from uni before that can you
please tell me what I've told me before
what did you order the you need to be
famous
he used to be active used to make the
funniest videos back then it wasn't like
corny but you look at KS I know you know
if you stop to your guns but now you're
but what you're scared of because I
think people in this day and age you
don't have associate it's fun it's not
because they don't have social media
they're ever had a bad experience or
they really like because it's so weird
thing because you can because you can
have you can have an Instagram and have
it on private and have your mum fully
you get me
so your Korean supreme cool if he come
to you and said yo bro this happened on
inside and he sees he sees whatever nosy
yeah exact so what so what Rick said has
a reason why he's not honest let's be
let's be a hundred percent transparency
yeah even though no say mister the
husband opine you have to be also it's
pot partly the reason why you don't have
so sure an Instagram because you have a
girlfriend that's why from now you know
which your projects for your business
but for me personally but I have a
Facebook Abbott where if you know me you
know me you have my number and the
amount of ads or whatever comes their
way and they may be in a relationship
I'm just saying you shouldn't really be
in a thing where people are adding you
it matters that's just life if your
things private from the jump you then
you're regulating the ad in anyway my
thing my things open you go just trust
yourself exactly you got just trust
yourself blinders on eyes on the fries
baby you need to put yourself in a
situation you don't like I missing
nothing in it personally yeah fair fair
yeah but yeah yeah I guess like a
I'm gonna make one up now cuz I'm
brilliant with this stuff right you
gotta financially with this stuff
alright it's a burning building and
there's a million pounds in that
building would you vote in a booty for
it no have a problem with here is people
in relationships have to have in to
dilute or even completely for this some
of the essences that make that make them
horses even if it's small things menial
things like minor things that don't have
an Instagram always big things like yeah
I'll real at football my girl hater so
calm which announcement do you see I'm
doing yeah oh yes so when you meet
someone everyone says oh yeah my other
half that's what they say yeah so what's
that so you're a hundred percent now so
what you have to do to meet yourself 50
percent that was a mercy so bid be 200%
be 200% broke no but I will give him he
is active on Facebook loose cuz who's
active on snap once again fool ya out
here out here he does you know you know
the fuel away leave you with one two
four singing in the car I don't know I
have but I don't use it like you send me
ship yeah I don't use Twitter but I have
an old work - yeah that's how I don't
miss anything you never catch me
tweeting but I said let's move on last
question we could be here all day -
there's so much would say um start with
you chip are you happy with where you
are in terms of what are so open the
holes everything if never happy I'm
right now they they say you're gonna
walk out these two you're gonna have a
hotel you're gonna drop will you be at
peace
with what you've done and never
everybody never ever will be wouldn't be
at peace with and and I couldn't I
couldn't say when I would be I couldn't
say I could I couldn't say if I was this
and if at this much money and if at that
and I DS my children like that and then
I walked out drop it I'll be happy so
you never know yeah like you say you're
happy you're happy in life you're a
happy person you're happy with the
things you have around you some of the
stuff you've done so far but if you say
at age of 30 right now am i content Who
I am no I'm not saying you're content
I'm saying that if you were to that fool
and die right now
where believe they like to you are you
happy with what you've done in your life
or do you wanna die
are you content are you happy would you
be cool I've seen more do you do would
you say that you've over achieved or
under achieved oh yeah hundred is dying
[Laughter]
do you feel that you've overachiever
under team if if not if you're 18 you're
not [ __ ] that let me good if you're 15
year old self yeah 15 remember how far
he looked half of your age now 15 if he
sort of brother you are now is he
laughing that man is he spotting you is
he saying I can't wait to I can't wait
for the next 15 years
oh [ __ ] is he saying you're broke broke
is insane you're with that ting is he
say it was funny POS
he spotted me because I've lived a
[ __ ] good life life weather yeah he's
funny but now you convert YouTube it's
your personal growth of who you are are
we talking about that are we talking
about where you are all of it like we
were saying the other day find your
happiness and everyone else will come
girl will come money will come
your happiness first because you might
be waking up in a job that's paying
before that too and it just didn't
really pop I've never made some money
and you know feelings already superpower
at the end of the day listen we'll all
all right we've all done things you've
all experienced could be I don't know
could be better
you're still doing your thing bro why
could it be better why could it be well
tell me why it could be better
I reckon because then you're taking away
something else from your experience to
be better in water I'm good man I don't
think I'll be honest with you myself
personally the things I've grown up with
or people who have been in my life and
the people are still starting my life
why do for them or why put up with they
I'm a great person where help people I
know I'm happy with me
if you go to anyone around me good to
work with me people around me but where
I'm in life dude I saw myself in so much
greater than this so your thing is money
money or where I am but money has never
do you mean in like seniority in WC so
once those people back I think is a lack
of clarity of ways want to be and how
you want to get there so I feel like
something I never really figured out is
how he threw that where as even people
but very vocal about
I don't feel so exactly that's all it's
very it's very English is be in the in
the same job for three years and be like
provide emotional I need a paycheck and
I inquire buy and if you do then your
fire
Gucci I said I wanted to be
second-degree like CIPD you're never too
old to cheap that's what we were saying
about happiness if your happiness you
can go into your work tomorrow
and quit so your plan could be let me
say for you then cut exactly you're
never too into mum no if you save if you
know if you know what you're doing I
said the plan can be you know what
you're doing bro and you save correctly
and do your thing then in a year you dip
and you're good happy with myself I'm
not content with where I am at the
moment happy because you're comparing
your like we were saying you not seeing
things you know rod he's person Don this
at forty five they spend on that
forty-six that's that time I said it's
about three or four times how do I feel
about the next thing it's gonna be sick
I'm gonna achieve what I came back from
America to do yeah this is what's gonna
happen
I'm gonna do my holidays do you know I'm
saying so what is wrong because there's
think there's things there's little
things are said like Mateus like for the
next 10 years what's it gonna bring and
you said multiple times and that for me
is dead answer I just know the agreed
among 10 years are gonna bring because
I'm just out here living but I'm gonna
go to [ __ ] your heart cool but apart
from that I know I'm gonna be good I
know I'm gonna be good I know we've me
I'm gonna be whoever is in my
relationship or is engine I mean a
family always in business you know I
mean all we've got weather weather is
just out here like traveling the world I
know as a man as a four year old man but
do you not feel any pressure to have
kids so you know I do that's cuz you I
know the next thing you know the next 2
news maybe sooner like it's popping in
it
I don't even present you know
where you guys are in life like Oh see
how long your situations been there but
for me my question was more personal to
you obviously obviously you think about
someone else every time yeah exactly
this is different
so I guess it is more for you gee full
pressures solely as a fit as a fit your
old man to have children
at all at all mad yeah not even talked
about you don't see you and good see
aunties yeah because I think they've
seen how I've been in these last copy
here is that is that yeah about you kids
but what you see is Overton exactly
where do I see does not question our
answered both oh no bombers can use
where do I see myself in 10 years I'm
excited about is people say that you're
you're you're ten years after you're 30
is your best ten years yeah of course is
gonna be better you're more secure think
about your 20s broke for free cause of
it is dead and imagine you chasing money
you're trying to do [ __ ] Bravo I'm going
to dates with eating plan in my pocket
you're more secure everything like
you're your most secure you know you you
know your self in it yeah it's fine in
yourself you know you know in this limbo
of of 2627 Oh should I be acting like a
22 year old or should I be acting I've
been going out more secure it was cool
good you know you know that's that's
what I'm saying maybe I don't know from
blow my trumpet here and I don't know
maybe that's just and I don't say this
again that yeah that's for me when I
duck when I hired 25 and I knew I was at
[ __ ] I'm here I'm here for a couple
years I got a five year visa I'm and
just go out all the time
I'm gonna be going out of town I was
earning good money and I was just out
here that's what I mean so that's why my
mind's out
oh yeah opportunity come today would you
would you go do that
what right now yeah and hadn't done it
before if you've done it already yeah
yeah yeah Murray you got I say we go
same opportunity see you think about it
and I think yeah but that's because I've
done it before but that's the thing as
well the reason I came because I could
have stayed there my visa is right now I
went there 2015 my visa only ran out
last month bro exactly had a five-year
visa in a car off to free and they pay
for that off the bridge that you're
gonna get best bet to go but that's why
maybe I'm looking at the next 10 years
different cuz I felt like I found that I
know I just want to be out here when I
was I was out there on my own and I had
to be going out by myself I had to be do
you make goes every year I don't make oh
I don't go that's the thing I don't make
goes I do but trash you may go I don't
make just feel look can I just say one
finger I feel robberies that I said how
now through like always man that was a
den also people are more intellectual
dinner I'm gonna call [ __ ] if I see [ __ ]
in it me know what they
my next 10 years I don't know where I'm
gonna be but just know you're gonna see
me and they're gonna be like wow nothing
still doing this thing yeah I'm gonna
have my baby side me maybe some use you
never know
still gonna be out here somewhere on
there's nothing negative about turn
turning is amazing nothing negative
about people just do you want I didn't
want to be an agony on and I don't want
to be telling you what this righteous
but enjoy yourself slow down yeah we're
just yeah you know exactly we're just
free guys on your challenge here listen
whatever money you spend you're gonna
make it back for this life I cannot
change in there
Thank You Thom producer H H Kate from
Bromley which is not in South London
thank you to our first guest chips round
of applause for the man he brought fire
we're gonna have him back he might even
become a regular a regular fixture the
fourth feature you're gonna see his hair
grow longer because I've been watching
his growth and it's been amazing to me
the fourth member of me goes out here
ASAP when he puts it up you open up with
anything that's for another time a value
a thank you chip thank you my sidekick
Robin my garlic bread my man my dwight
yorke - Andy Cole listen we're gonna
catch you next time all the love people
look at yourself thank you miss